the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right let's start off with a quick
list of important concepts for the week
and I'm gonna push you right along today
I want to get to something what do you
got static equilibrium okay so yo M's
from ecstatic okay good
another concept for the week
damping yeah and what are we been
talking about all week vibration
okay so vibration damping okay more
what's the whole general subject that
we've in case vibration in it's an
introduction to what after making it
we've been making an assumption that we
haven't made before yeah linear we're
have been studying this has been an
intro to linear systems we can only do
things like transfer functions that sort
of thing with by assuming linearity
anything else what have I just spent the
last two lectures deriving for you and
showing you transfer functions in fact
I've shown you three
all right all right that's bad it's
beginning to get at what we've been
talking about so introduction to linear
systems we've been studying vibration as
one at one implementation or application
of linear systems we've been looking at
single degree of freedom vibration
problems only so far and we've found
frequency response functions these
frequency response function tell you the
response of a system to what kind of an
input what are the characteristics of
the input that we've been looking at
what we call harmonic single frequency
cosine Omega T like input cosine Omega T
sine Omega T e to the I Omega T one
frequency
repetitive it's called a harmonic input
so for a linear system we've also we're
talking about what we call the
steady-state response what's that mean
what is okay put that into words
so you turn the motor on the whole
building shakes settles down and just
has a steady vibration you're dealing
with so after any startup transients
that died out it's a steady state
response so if you're doing if you have
a linear system and you're putting in
some F naught e to the I Omega T force
real part of steady state response what
is the frequency of the response right
so for linear systems the steady state
response the frequency of the output
always it's a property of a linear
system okay so a couple really important
things to remember here good now we're
going to move on to a problem oh and
what I think I usually do ask of you is
are there any major questions something
left over from lectures I'm probably
done in the last week it just isn't
going down
how do you get gravity to go away in the
equation actually this is the most
common question that's been asked with
the TAS this week of professor Gossard
of me so the sale seems to be a little
bit of misunderstanding about and this
is the subject of static equilibrium
versus unstretched spring kind of
positions okay I think I'll just deal
with that right away
you're familiar with this problem okay
see em and you're and most of you're
comfortable with the notion of measuring
X from the unstretched spring position
right so that's what I've done right
here now you add gravity though and let
it find its equilibrium position under
gravity it's going to be at some other
location right and I'm just going to
call that X static at static
displacement now when you turn that on
the X the harmonic excitation or even
grab it and let it go from initial
condition where will it vibrate around
it's going to vibrate with around the
static equilibrium position so i'm going
i'm here's my system here's my free body
diagram got all the gravities and C X's
and K X's and X dots and so forth in it
complete right I can write an equation
of motion for that system which you've
done lots of times and it has a gravity
in it but now I'm going to say look
here's my x coordinate it stretches down
X static and on top of that I'm going to
add a little dynamic motion and I'm
going to describe that as x equals X
static a constant plus the dynamic
movement with respect to X static take
the time derivative of it because this
is constant it goes away and two time
derivatives so X dot is X dot d and X
double dot is X double dot the dynamic
quantity take these three and plug them
into here MX d double dot c XD dot but
the K term you still have X static in it
don't ya the original KX but breaks into
two pieces but on the right hand side is
my mg plus F of T like before but
Ecstatic is must be equal to mg in order
for static equilibrium to have existed
everybody agree with that another way to
see that is let's say there's no dynamic
motion this term goes away this term
goes away this term goes away
turn off the excitation you're left with
that equals this and that's what says it
sits in the static equilibrium position
if those two are equal they cancel
leaving you with this so if you had
understood this in the beginning you
could have said let's let's start let's
make our inertial coordinate from the
static equilibrium position just let the
thing find its static equilibrium
position set the inertial coordinate
measured from there and you would direct
you would get to this equation with the
possible confusion of having to deal
with the free body diagram because the
free body diagram still has on it mg and
the spring force that comes from the
static position right so if I were
drawing a free if I were doing this and
just say I want to go directly to this
equation I would draw the free body
diagram that would have KX d CX d dot f
mg but then I would also just put in
here there's one more force K times X
static or Delta or whatever you want to
call it you know there's some ecstatic
and you know because you're doing this
because you know this about the problem
you know this cancels that and it won't
appear in the equation of motion so to
be able to do anytime you confront it
with a problem that has gravity which
causes a static deflection or results in
a static equilibrium position it might
be zero in your coordinate life pendulum
you look at it and you say now in the
equation of motion that you derive from
the unstretched spring force position is
the mg term a function of the motion
coordinate and in this case it is not so
it doesn't matter what x becomes this
star this force stays constant it
doesn't enter into the dynamics of the
problem and so if you could find right
if you have a write in equation of
motion and you come up with an mg term
that doesn't have a theta or an X or any
variable in it you know that there's
another way to write that equation about
static equilibrium and you'll be able to
get rid of it and simplify the math
basically ok now we got to move I want
to move on to the problem of the day and
the problem of the day I've written up
here
that's the last classes list you've got
a motor fan or something
it's got a rotating imbalance it's got a
flexible base
it's got a lot of vertical vibration
driving too crazy
the rotation rate this is a you know a
pump or something with a rotating some
rotating mass inside has some
eccentricity so it's causing some
external force I'm causing a by force it
results in vertical vibration the
rotation rate of that fan is 1750 rpm
the weight of this motor sitting on this
frame is 500 pounds when you set this
motor and bolt it down on that frame the
frame deflects 0.026 inches and this
thing's vibrating like crazy now your
assistant comes in and says I got a
solution for this we're gonna put braces
in here and those braces will double the
K the spring constant of the mount of
the thing and he or she asserts that he
thinks it will cut the amplitude of
response in half cut the vibration
amplitude in half so you're going to do
the calculations today to see whether or
not this is a good idea and we're going
to begin so assignment one is come up
with a simple lump parameter model
mass's springs dashpots
of this system so that you can model it
so we've only been doing single degree
freedom systems it's probably and it
looks something like that
so come up with a lump parameter model
of that and we've got what four eight
well we could do four groups easily here
of four or five each so break into four
groups come up first with the fine end
group one will put group on right here
and group two here and three and four
there so to come when you get when your
group figures out and we got to move
right along because there's several
parts of this just come up sketch your
model that you're going to do it with
and then part two right after that is to
compute the natural frequency of the
system we're going to eventually have to
compute the transfer functions and then
try out the fix and see if the fix makes
things better or worse so let's come
first first assignment' come up with a
lump parameter model and find the
natural frequency for me groups and get
talking and it's really some M e omega
squared cosine a D and this it comes
from the equivalent little mass on some
arm east going around and around inside
this is the equivalent unbalanced mass
here okay
so I keep coming up put your models up
here yeah well let's go back to we've
done this problem about four times over
the course of homework in the term you
know block with an arm with a mass on
the end at the e is the little length is
the length of the arm and the mass on
the N is essentially the location of the
center of mass of the rotating part
right so the other three groups need to
draw a model up and come up with a
natural frequency
one of the annoyances of this problem
into his nasty English units you all
remember what G is in English units I
want radians per second
yeah but why do you convert English
eight inches to Feet and you're done
because you know G and feet per second
squared so rather than do three
conversions do one well that's one you
know then you know G so you could do it
that way sure I don't care I just want
them I want the root of the result guy's
got a number
which is Group one you guys are one you
got a number
give me how many MIT students does it
take to convert from inches to Feet well
in this this equation does it give you
her two radians um sure
and you just made this substitution in
here so it hasn't done anything to
change to Hertz write that down what a
struggle okay good that's good you can
leave it
all right we've all converged to about
121 right that was quite a struggle was
that the unit sir was there you partly
it was Hertz and you guys haven't had
you know we're dealing with nothing but
equations for weeks and I actually have
to do real engineering numbers has
thrown you a little bit but so it's
about 121 and that G over Delta thing is
really handy you know now we want now I
want to know what is the response of
this system to this input given the
frequency of the input is 1750 rpm and
rpm n is often written how is it related
to frequency in Hertz or cycles per
second anybody know this is revolutions
per minute what would be revolutions per
second is that the same thing as Hertz
so revolution is something going around
got one full time around is 2pi it's one
cycle
so if you do 60 cycles in a minute how
many of you in a second one so this rpm
divided by 60 equals F in cycles per
second or Hertz okay rpm divided by 60
gives you revolutions per second well
excuse me I was talking about will do
that get rid of that that's the relation
you want and what's the relationship
between Omega and F for every cycle you
get 2pi radians okay so now compute I
want to give me an estimate find oppose
my problem here so Part one you've done
part two here is to get an estimate of
the magnitude of the steady state
response and we've been talking about
transfer functions so it's probably at
applica applying a transfer function
here I would put your symbolic answer up
first would be a terrific idea
thank you all when you think you have
kind of a symbolic so approach to this
go write it up and well that way I can
know where you need a little help if any
that's okay so you don't know K so just
just leave that as a undetermined
quantity if not it what it what is well
well let you guys keep working for a
second then we'll talk about it so you
don't know K so just leave it as an
unknown I don't do that just call it F
naught but now plug in some numbers for
what you do know
so one quantity you're going to need to
make over mega n right so write that one
down when you get it what's omega over
Omega N and then move on from there now
there's a little pitfall here that
you're all running into and that is
you're taking the positive square root
is written it's the whole quantity down
there squared square root and you're
writing it one minus Omega squared and
this thing's going to turn out negative
on you if you're not careful but it you
can flip it around it's really the
absolute value of that quantity because
it's a that quantity squared square root
so it can be plus or minus
so you got one point five for one point
five for what one point five is your
ratio okay write it down just write the
ratio that's what you need one point
five and you got this is 4/5 here that's
what you guys at work done okay so like
0.8
they took calculate Omega Omega n you
have a 183 divided by what was your
Omega in not 60 well you got to divide
1750 by 60 to get F and then you got to
multiply by 2 pi right I'm doing it for
the benefit of everybody in the room
here point a F naught over K all right
now we're getting somewhere
point eight point eight what do you guys
have here you got one over 1.3 how's
that work out all right so about point
eight ok so you've come to the
conclusion that the magnitude of that
steady state response is about point
eight F naught over K and we call that F
naught over K weak you know in lecture I
call it the static response the book
calls it the static response as it is
this it is it the same static responses
we're talking about here don't confuse
it to this was the effect of gravity on
the system the static response we're
talking about here is if the frequency
of this excitation went to zero then the
response this would stretch that spring
by the amount we're calling X static F
naught over K all right so now you know
that you're operating at a frequency
what's the frequency ratio that you
found Omega over Omega n you had that
was an intermediate step here all right
one point five all right now you're
going to the proposed fixed is to double
the stiffness double the stiffness and
somebody so you're going from what's the
we want now we want to compute this
result if you double the stiffness and
the person who proposed that thinks it's
going to have the response that's the
proposal so double the stiffness and in
order to get finished here what effect
does changing the stiffness have on this
system
well you're jumping to an answer
intermediate step here what does it do
to the natural frequency there's a
natural frequency change if you change
the stiffness okay so the natural
frequency is normally some kind of K
over m right now we also know it's G
over Delta but we're going to double the
stiffness so what does that do to the
natural frequency does the M change okay
so what's the this is Omega n before
Omega and after equals right okay and
that is what does that do to your
frequency ratio
so your freak the effect of changing the
stiffness changes the natural frequency
and that changes the ratio of the input
frequency to the natural frequency and
that will change this calculation here
right so come up with a new value for
this and we got a number what's the
frequency ratio after
I wanted to know the frequency ratio
this is a after is equal to the
frequency ratio de was something to do
with root 2 here the natural frequency
is going to go up or down by a factor of
root 2 double K the natural frequency go
up by a square root of 2 so the
frequency ratio after the natural
frequency goes up by the square root of
2 that's the same as root 2 over 2 here
so the whole thing drops down so a 1.5
times square root of 2 over 2 what is it
alright 1.07 now what is figure out this
quantity
pardon 3.4 and and did you put in a 2
here right so this is the this is the
this is the correct expression to be
using but now in this new problem this
was before in this in this problem
afterwards exes Teddy state is F naught
over 2 K if doubled the stiffness all
over this quantity Omega squared over
Omega N squared minus 1 but with the new
frequency ratio this is now 1.07 you do
this number what do you get 3 point
would you tense a three point four
roughly F naught over K so you can so
you have apples and apples together I
want to compare up to the F naught over
KD before after end up with a factor of
three point four so should you make the
change none of the bad idea what if you
certain you rented a situation like this
before going all that trouble a cutting
steel and getting out the torch
you know the welding system take
yourself a great big weight and walk up
and thump some weight on top of this
thing and see if it gets better or worse
because if I doubled the mass of this
system what would happen
it's gonna go the other direction right
this this will go up by a factor of root
two and then this this denominator
you're getting pushing it further out
and you'll instead of being at point
eight you'll be down further